[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález un nuevo
terreno de disputa entre republicanos y
demócratas en eeuu ha generado la
nominación de un nuevo juez de la corte
suprema esto después de la muerte de
ruth báder ginsburg una jueza
progresista que sin duda alguna dejó una
huella importante en la historia de eeuu
veamos de quién se trata
en la izquierda estadounidense ha
perdido a su icono wifi de games break
una pionera en la defensa de los
derechos de la mujer murió este viernes
después de luchar contra 5 episodios de
cáncer a lo largo de su vida esta jueza
de la corte suprema de eeuu usó una
larga carrera legal impulsada por sus
propias luchas como mujer en una
profesión dominada por hombres en la
facultad de derecho de harvard fue una
de las nueve mujeres de una clase de 500
estudiantes después de graduarse de
columbia como la mejor de su año todavía
se enfrentó a dificultades para
encontrar trabajo ya que los jueces
federales no querían contratar mujeres
en 1970 fundó la primera revista
jurídica dedicada exclusivamente a los
derechos de la mujer
dos años después ayudó a lanzar una
sección similar dentro de la poderosa
unión americana de libertades civiles y
para 1974 el organismo había participado
en más de 300 demandas por
discriminación de género así ginsburg se
ganó una reputación con su trabajo
pero constante favoreciendo las batallas
ganables por encima de los casos
llamativos en 1994 fue nominada a la
corte suprema por bill clinton
convirtiéndola en la segunda mujer en
servir en el máximo órgano judicial de
eeuu allí continuó defendiendo los
derechos de las mujeres con sentencias
sobre temas controversiales como el
aborto el matrimonio entre personas del
mismo sexo y la inmigración era
reconocida por ser una gran disidente
del gobierno de trump y cuando hablaba
de su visión de la ley durante discursos
en todo el país siempre era recibida con
ovaciones cuando la gente le preguntaba
cuántos de los nueve escaños del
tribunal debían ocupar mujeres ella
siempre daba la misma respuesta
wendy dice cuando crees que habrá
suficiente
es obvio cuando haya 9
su baja estatura combinada con su
rechazo a dejarse intimidar la hizo
ascender al estatus de ícono de la
cultura pop en una generación mucho más
joven
la popular magistrada del más alto
tribunal del país era venerada por los
progresistas y odiada por los
conservadores
la nominación de donald trump de dos
jueces de la corte suprema cambió el
balance de la corte de cinco a cuatro
por los conservadores el fallecimiento
de ginsberg podría reforzar la tendencia
conservadora en la entidad
esta elección de un nuevo juez ha
generado discrepancias en torno al
escenario político que está viviendo
eeuu porque están a semanas de las
elecciones presidenciales y el tema pues
obviamente sea post politizado era
inevitable que esto sucediera pese a
este escenario cuatro años atrás había
opiniones muy diferentes en torno a la
elección de un nuevo juez de la corte
suprema también en un año electoral
veamos
la constitución es bastante clara sobre
lo que se supone que debe suceder ahora
cuando hay una vacante en la corte
suprema- el presidente de eeuu debe
nominar a alguien su nombre
con los demás detenerlo se llama demora
demora demora
si el senado de eeuu que es controlado
por los republicanos aprueba la elección
de su candidato esta bancada habría
elegido a tres de los nueve jueces que
componen esta corte veamos
y dejemos que el pueblo estadounidense
decida
el senador revisará apropiadamente el
asunto cuando considere la calificación
del nominado para que pueda ser el
próximo presidente nominar a aquí
ya estamos escuchando afirmaciones
incorrectas de que no hay tiempo
suficiente para examinar y confirmaron
nominado podemos desacreditar este mito
en unos 30 segundos autorizo a camps a
partir de hoy quedan 43 días hasta el 3
de noviembre y 104 días hasta el final
de este congreso estamos hablando de un
cargo que es vitalicio que puede moldear
la legislación de temas como el sistema
y la atención médica en eeuu el derecho
al voto el derecho de las minorías el
aborto la migración entre otros temas
esta elección tiene lugar en un año de
elección presidencial de pandemia de
incendios forestales en california
tensiones con china manifestaciones y el
movimiento black life matters el legado
de ruth báder ginsburg y la lucha por su
sucesión son nuestro tema hoy en el
debate de france 24 para analizar este
tema entonces hemos invitado a maría
herrera ellas estratega republicana y
también es vicepresidenta de la asamblea
hispana del partido republicano en la
ciudad de miami en el estado de florida
también está con nosotros michel
nat analista política estratega
demócrata y lawrence weiner él es
abogado y analista político ustedes
también son parte de este debate dejen
todos sus comentarios en la france24
guión al piso s y arroba sant y luego
deje los comentarios o las preguntas
también con la etiqueta numeral el
debate efe 24 comienzo con maría herrera
preguntándole por la jueza ginsburg como
un icono que dejó muchos cambios y dejó
lecciones en eeuu cuáles son sus
impresiones antes de entrar en materia
política
bueno yo coincido con el análisis que
has llevado a cabo creo que fue un icono
en el ámbito legal
una jueza progresista defensora de los
derechos de la mujer contra la
discriminación y quizás demasiado
liberal para mi gusto pero una mujer que
se merece el respeto de todos los
juristas en el estado en eeuu y a nivel
mundial y que ha sido un referente para
todos todos los abogados en estados
unidos realmente mis hermanas opinión
bueno yo creo que yo utilizaría otro
término no progresista ella fue una
mujer quien interpretó a la constitución
de una forma moderna es una mujer que
estaba educado fue educada en los años
50 ella misma experimentó mucha de
describir discriminación no podía llegar
a un puesto con un bufete bufete de
abogados no había ninguna oferta para
ella y tenía que encontrar otro camino
para entrar en su carrera indicada que
es la ley derecho y luego paso por paso
quería y vio y quería dedicarse a
confrontación y cambios de todos los
obstáculos para mujeres y para minorías
en eeuu y eso es lo que hizo eso es
interpretación y uso de sus habilidades
de una forma moderna no es progresista
lawrence combinar su opiniones sobre la
jueza ginsburg
bueno es una figura sobresaliente en la
era moderna de nuestro corte estoy de
acuerdo con mis colegas ha sido
sumamente importante fue una juez seguro
una ancla de la rama progresista para
este recuerdo que la señora en eso y
también fue una figura cultural en
nuestra cultura muy importante fue un
símbolo para muchas mujeres muchos
profesionales muchos en el programa
judicial y alguien que todo el mundo
pudiera respetar o estar de acuerdo
ideológicamente o no
el escenario político en eeuu en este
momento ya lo decíamos tiene muchísimas
aristas que están afectando diferentes
aspectos de la vida diaria y de la vida
política de ese país la pandemia las
relaciones con china en la candidatura
de donald trump a una elección
presidencial en las próximas semanas
serán los comicios también estas
protestas ciudadanas que lo
mencionábamos por el movimiento black
life matters el escenario político es
difícil esto dificultará mariah la
elección de este de esta vacante que
queda ahora allí después de la muerte de
guinzburg
no yo no creo no debería de afectar
puesto que el presidente tiene
legalmente la capacidad y además la
obligación no de nominar a una candidata
para reemplazar a la recién fallecida
ruth ginsburg y además el partido
republicano controla el senado en eeuu
necesitan 50 votos y hoy con las
afirmaciones del senador por yuta mitt
romney se confirma que el senado va a
contar con los suficientes votos para
confirmar a la candidata que proponga el
presidente de donald trump este sábado
por otra parte es cierto que es
alarmante el estadio social que estamos
viviendo y que declaraciones como las
que ha hecho por ejemplo alexandra
ocasio cortes o algunos de los
demócratas pues no ayuda puesto que en
sus palabras han dicho que esto debe
ayudarnos la afa el fallecimiento de
ruth quien suerte voy a ayudar nos para
radicalizarnos y eso es algo que bajo mi
punto de vista es inaceptable
y si le hago la misma pregunta pero pero
hago énfasis en el escenario de las
elecciones presidenciales estamos a muy
pocas semanas y la bancada demócrata ha
pedido al presidente que no haga una
elección de ningún juez o no proponga
ningún nombre hasta después de los
comicios sí bueno quiero empezar con
esto que para con la nominación de la
jueza aliens por el voto en el senado en
el en el que el momento fue 96 391 96 de
los senadores actuales del momento
votaron a favor de ella así que si
llegamos a este año 2020 y pensamos en
lo que estamos viendo en el margen es
casi este negocio es muy poquito
entonces la polarización del país es
algo muy muy concreto y de mucho riesgo
eso complica bastante para nosotros yo
soy demócrata y
cien por ciento de plata en mi sangre
tengo nada más que soy demócrata y eso
nos ha complicado bastante porque
inyecta fuerza otro tema muy importante
y que tiene un peso y un que es
relevante para él para los años que
vienen que ha llegado y encima de todo
esto es sinceramente trágico que en un
momento cuando hay 200 miles de
norteamericanos que han perdido su vida
desde enero por comer o cuando hay 6 mil
millones no de casos en el mundo por
comer y cuando es por lo menos 7 mil
healthcare workers médicos enfermeras
técnicos o más han perdido su vida en la
lucha contra joven eso es donde quieren
hacer la confrontación los republicanos
no quieren tocar el tema del paquete de
de salida y paquete de ayuda financiera
para los norteamericanos quieren forzar
esto y la confrontación entre los dos
partidos es trágico y es una falta de
liderazgo en el máximo tanto del
presidente de trump como de el liderazgo
republicano de los senadores pero en su
análisis de este escenario
michelle lo mencionaba la gran
polarización que hay en eeuu en este
momento para elegir esta vacante que es
de suma importancia y es tal vez uno de
los organismos de la política
estadounidense más importantes incluso
ha sido llamada como una tercera cámara
dentro de la política estadounidense
si efectivamente estamos en un ambiente
supremamente valorizado y hay una
ansiedad y tensión en la sociedad que
jamás hemos visto en muchos años
entonces este es otro elemento desde
tensión de esta polarización que vamos a
ver ahora vamos a escuchar mucho de
ambos lados sobre los principios si
debiéramos elegir un nuevo país justo al
lado de las elecciones o esperar que el
pueblo habla la realidad es que no hay
principios en ese debate porque la
constitución es claro hay capacidad de
nombrar y elegir la cuestión es de puro
poder político y esa es una batalla
fuerte y poderoso y con grandes
consecuencias para el futuro del país
porque como usted mencionó esa es una
rama judicial muy importante y los
jueces sirven por vida
entonces si todo el otro puede nombrar
su tercer juez
y puede tener una influencia sobre
nuestro política por muchos décadas en
el futuro por eso las consecuencias de
ese debate son tan altos y ese es el
temor de la bancada demócrata en maría
precisamente el presidente de donald
trump
ha sido criticado por querer hacer este
proceso muy rápido él ha dicho que va a
dar una nominación la va a dar a conocer
entre el viernes a más tardar el sábado
se está presionando un poco al
presidente todo esto por el marco en el
que está de una elección en donde el
escenario político y económico ya no
está jugando a su favor de cara a la
reelección
no yo no creo yo creo que si miramos a
la historia en eeuu ha habido 15
ocasiones en la que una vacante en el
tribunal supremo durante un año
electoral además en la confirmación de
la jueza ruth ginsburg se llevó a cabo
en 42 días de la jueza o connor en 33
días del juez steven en 16 días yo creo
que se están haciendo las cosas de
manera correcta
además apelando a las propias
declaraciones de joe biden en febrero de
2016 él decía que el pueblo americano se
merece un tribunal de justicia a un
tribunal supremo de conformado por nueve
jueces a tiempo completo y el mismo
presidió también la confirmación de un
juez del tribunal supremo cuando lo
nominó reagan yo creo que es algo
completamente aceptable y además estoy
completamente de acuerdo con lo que ha
dicho
mi compañero de qué se trata
una confrontación y una lucha de poder
político
pues de traslado esa afirmación entonces
a michele una confrontación por poder
político entonces lo que estamos viendo
acá y se está dejando de lado la
importancia que tiene este cargo
simplemente por la necesidad de tener un
tercer juez a favor de los republicanos
lo que el análisis que estamos viendo de
la del lado de los conservadores y tener
toda la narrativa que lleva es
completamente falsa
hay hechos básicos faltan 42 días para
selecciones nacionales hay gente que ya
hay hay ciudadanos que ya han votado y
su voluntad y sus expresiones de de sus
valores y sus expectativas es lo que
forman y te dan el petróleo a su voto
hay gente que han votado el jueves y
viernes pasado inclusive en mi estado de
virginia commonwealth de virginia donde
empezamos con massachusetts la historia
de nuestro país empezó en james chang ya
han votado con la expectativa de ciertas
cosas en la en en la corte suprema eso
fue un un güey un terremoto una llegada
de algo máximo de destrucción que la
jueza la puesta icónica y muy muy
querida falleció después de años de su
batalla contra el cáncer lo que están
haciendo
los senadores en el liderazgo del
senador inclusive unos que no están para
no se han puesto para la reelección que
se van a jubilar con como el senador
lamar alexander del estado de tennessee
es
in aceptable ellos pueden empezar para
los resultados que vamos a tener en el
mes de noviembre y no hay nada que la
corte suprema y su en sus funciones va a
sufrir sin tener una una o un juez es un
power up al máximo y toda la gente que
han han tenido experiencia como
historiadores y analistas tanto abogados
como periodistas lo están diciendo pero
en su opinión al respecto un pavor grave
como lo dice nuestra invitada
bueno ese es un par grave porque los
republicanos en este momento tienen
poder estoy seguro con todo respecto a
mi colega señor ban a que si los
demócratas tuvieron la oportunidad ellos
harían lo mismo porque porque tener su
aliado ideológico en la corte suprema de
los estados unidos es algo sumamente
importante para cualquier partido
político
entonces los republicanos quieren
colocar quieren poner su marca en el
corte suprema que va a demorar por
décadas yo creo que los demócratas
harían igual lo mismo lo que estamos
viendo es algo que bajo la constitución
es perfectamente legítimo moralmente y
políticamente tiene que decidir los
votantes si es aceptable o no ellos van
a tener la oportunidad de votar entre
ahora y el 30 y noviembre y el escenario
tiene similitudes con lo que sucedió
hace cuatro años
sigo con usted porque
tengo aquí una pregunta para contarle a
los televidentes de américa latina para
que usted nos explicó un poco cómo es
este proceso prácticamente esto está en
manos de tres personas y son tres
personas que son republicanas
el presidente donald trump envía la
propuesta al senado el senador graham
que es el presidente del comité de
justicia en la debate y la prueba y
luego el senador mcconnell que es el
líder de la mayoría en el senado convoca
a la ratificación en el pleno del senado
de eeuu esto prácticamente ya está dicho
desde su punto de vista no hay opción
para que los republicanos puedan ganarse
otra ficha en esta corte
bueno eso es como mentir a la señora
herrera
con la declaración del cerebro a mí que
él iba a apoyar la consideración de your
way en este periodo éste da a los
republicanos una gran ventaja porque
ellos tienen una ventaja de tres
senadores en el senado en y con la
votación del vicepresidente que si están
empatados el vicepresidente voto en
realidad tiene una ventaja de cuatro
senadores necesitan los demócratas que
cuatro celadores republicanos voten
contra el candidato para tener un chance
dos senadores republicanos ya han dicho
que no van a votar por un candidato
antes de estas elecciones entonces
necesitan dos más si mantienen el señor
cano mantiene infieles
los demás de los senadores republicanos
no hay chance para los demócratas frenar
este tren es va a ser elegido por las
personas que hemos hablado
michelle de su opinión en torno a lo que
podrían hacer la bancada demócrata ya
vemos cómo está el panorama para la
elección estas tres personas son
republicanas que otras opciones tienen
entonces los demócratas para ejercer
allí presión y lograr su cometido que lo
que quieren tener otra vez allí hay dos
hechos que quiero agregar que en primer
lugar estamos en la época como dije de
hace faltan 442 días para las elecciones
en sí el 3 de noviembre hay la voluntad
popular en el país que es muy muy obvio
está afuera está en las calles está en
los medios del día tras día tras día
también hay lo hay encuestas encuestas
muy respetadas en los últimos días que
están indicando que la mayoría de los
ciudadanos del país de los dos partidos
de ambos partidos y también de los
independientes quieren esperar
así que voluntad popular es un factor
también en términos de cómo funciona el
senado yo trabajé en el congreso varios
años como conoce señor combina y también
nuestra otra colega yo abordando los
beneficios que merece el vio en la en el
comité de asuntos de relaciones
exteriores hay un proceso en el senado
ella en el comité de justicia que indica
que los dos líderes el republicano y la
demócrata en este caso el senador del
supremo del estado de salud caroline y
la senadora diane feinstein del estado
de california ellos deben y pueden
encontrar un acuerdo entre ellos para el
proceso de la nominación y la audiencia
para la célula candidato o candidata
para la jueza para esta posición y esto
es algo que no están respetando los
líderes del partido republicano desde
hasta z desde el inicio hasta el hasta
ahora y todavía estamos en período de
luto yo tengo negro puesto esta noche
por una razón la jueza pedir órdenes
berg acaba de epages ser es va a estar
en el capitolio en una ceremonia de
honor el día viernes entonces podemos
esperar no hay una razón por forzarlo
tan rápido y de una forma
inconscientemente raf si maría retomó la
comunicación con usted quiénes son esos
posibles candidatos o candidatas por
parte de los republicanos para este para
esta plaza que el vacante en la corte
bueno pues aquí en el sur de florida
conocemos a la jueza lago a una mujer
cubano americana nacida en high alía de
padres inmigrantes que además ahora se
encuentra en el undécimo distrito en la
corte de apelaciones muy querida por
todos los hispanos una mujer no solo por
el hecho de ser hispana de ser mujer
sino una mujer conservadora católica que
con sus con su vida y sus decisiones ha
marcado y ha demostrado ser una mujer de
una alta estimación y claramente muy
ética y por otro lado también yo creo
que tenemos que considerar a mi padre no
también una jueza que ahora se encuentra
en la corte de apelaciones en el séptimo
distrito y que es además madre de siete
hijos dos de ellos adoptados de haití
también católica conservadora y son
mujeres y referentes que seguramente
harían
increíble en el tribunal supremo y que
cuentan con el apoyo de los
conservadores estamos muy ilusionados
por este proceso de nominación
confirmación y reemplazo de la jueza
ruth ginsburg que en paz descanse
lawrence en eeuu ya lo decíamos esta
corte goza de un alto prestigio pero en
los últimos años ese prestigio se ha
visto un poco entorpecido por hechos y
por decisiones que ha tomado la corte y
por diferentes situaciones en los que se
ha visto inmersa desde el punto de vista
de sus integrantes que ya lo decíamos
son cargos vitalicios entendiendo estas
diferencias de cargas entre los partidos
no se incrementa un poco ese
desprestigio digámoslo así ante los
votantes ante los ciudadanos no está
perdiendo un poco esa neutralidad o esa
capacidad de dedicarse específicamente a
analizar la constitución en vez de estar
con una carga política
bueno eso no buena pregunta yo no diría
que ha perdido prestigio pero yo creo
que si hay un riesgo que una neutralidad
con que hemos vivido por los últimos
años
o sea una diferencia básicamente de
cinco conservadores contra cuatro
liberales aunque esas son estimaciones
con este 5 a 4 siempre hay cambios de
posiciones y siempre hay como decisiones
muy estrechos si se vuelve a hacer 6 a 3
va a bajar
solo solidificar un control conservador
sobre el corte que tiene preocupado los
liberales y los progresistas en el país
pero hay una cosa que hay que recordar
tenemos una historia donde jueces
nombrados por un lado político han
vuelto o no han sido tan fiel y tan
rígido en la aplicación de la ley o sea
ya hemos visto con el rey roberts
que ha enojado a muchos conservadores
por sus decisiones entonces a una vez
que está en el corte tienen plena
libertad de elegir como ellos decidan y
ha habido sus sorpresas en el pasado y
puede haber sorpresas en el futuro pero
definitivamente va a ser menos neutral
el corte va a ser más sólido conservador
si llega a nombrar y ratificar este
nuevo weiss por el presidente de trump y
el senador republicano así es voy
llegando al final del programa quiero
que hagamos las conclusiones para el
cierre
michele mandato usted que cree que va a
suceder a partir del viernes fecha que
dio el presidente de trump de fecha
límite para presentar unos nominados y
que comience ya este proceso en firme
que cree usted que va a pasar en esta
corte
bueno hoy vamos a ver lo que va a pasar
o bien es el sábado con el nombramiento
que va aa darnos el presidente trump
inmediatamente los dos lados van a
analizar eso la persona obviamente ha
dicho que va a ser una mujer y vamos a
tener las reacciones las reacciones van
a hacer aún más concretas y específicas
ahora en ese momento hay mucha
especulación entonces qué va a pasar el
liderazgo del congreso tanto demócrata
por un lado como los republicanos van a
tener reuniones de emergencia para
hablar y para especificar su estrategia
en adelante y vamos a vamos a ver vamos
a evaluar y vamos a insistir en que haya
más diálogo acerca de de el proceso y en
la necesidad de entender bien la persona
nombrada no hay prisa no hay urgencia
para ese nombramiento eso es un juego de
poder nada
los demócratas nosotros vamos a jugar
tenemos nuestro nuestra posición
michelle ya su vez el plan y mariah a su
conclusión un minuto para el cierre
bueno pues yo he ido tomando notas de lo
que ha dicho lo que han dicho mis
compañeros y quería básicamente decir
que yo creo que los republicanos sí se
han mostrado respetuosos en todo momento
que hemos y sea se está guardando un
período de luto y que además la elección
popular es clara el senado tiene mayoría
republicana desde 2014 2016 sale
vencedor donald trump 2018 se confirma
la mayoría republicana en el senado por
último y con respecto a lo que ha dicho
mi compañero largo yo también coincido
en que una vez esta jueza sea nominada y
confirmada tendrá absoluta libertad e
independencia judicial además que le
exigimos para votar en conciencia y de
acuerdo a su récord entonces nada más
que sea un proceso como siempre es en
eeuu absolutamente impecable y lograr en
su conclusión para el programa
bueno yo creo que ese es un momento
histórico yo creo que este es un proceso
de gran importancia de gran
consecuencias para el futuro del país
entonces va a ser muy interesante como
sucede y cómo reacciona el pueblo de los
eeuu parece que se presenta y trabajo
tiene los votos pero nada es seguro y de
una vez nombrado este va a cambiar la
cara del condición problema por muchos
décadas
bueno y sin duda alguna los ojos del
mundo estarán fijados en eeuu no
solamente por el avance de la pandemia
que ha dejado impresionado a la
humanidad entera con los 6.8 millones de
casos por las elecciones presidenciales
que tienen lugar en las próximas semanas
y ahora por esta nueva disputa y este
nuevo capítulo que se abre en la
historia de la corte suprema de este
país un organismo como ya lo decíamos
importante en la toma de decisiones en
eeuu en este país norteamericano le
quiero agradecer a mis tres invitados
del día de hoy por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en el debate de france 24
haber expuesto
para nuestra teleaudiencia todas sus
opiniones en torno a este tema y ustedes
también los invito para que sigan
dejando sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
france24 hay mucho más para ver
[Música]